[Applause]
[Music]
so what the Days of Future past film
coming out I figured it'd be an
extremely good idea to do a video on
this topic because I think that there
are a lot of people who have a lot of
questions about the original storyline
and how close the movie will be with the
original storyline but also because I
think that people are fascinated by the
idea of alternate universes and they're
fascinated by the idea of the depiction
of some of their favorite Marvel
characters and alternate universes and
with the Days of Future past comic being
one of the most popular and kind of a
forerunner to the alternate universe
concept in Marvel Comics this really
seems to be the best time to do a
discussion on this type of thing and
particularly about the Days of Future
past storyline itself so before we get
too far into our discussion about the
Days of Future past comic there are a
couple dates that I would like for you
to keep in mind the first date is 2013
and the second date is 1980 and the
reason why these dates are important is
because the comic will pick up in 2013
and then it will transition in 1980 and
then it will bounce back and forth
between the two dates as events unfold
and their respective timelines so the
comic starts with Kitty Pryde heading to
some unknown destination in New York to
meet with Wolverine along the way we
learn a few things and what we learn is
that this future is very dystopian and
it's very dark New York has been left in
a state of decay and whatever event it
was that led up to New York being this
way has also affected both Canada and
the United States itself and possibly
the world
in addition once Kitty Pryde meets with
Wolverine we also learned that Wolverine
is part of a group called the Canadian
resistance army he is also supplying
Kitty Pryde with a piece of of a device
of some sort in order to complete what
is referred to as the jammer now we
don't really know what the jammer does
or what it's for but we do know that
it's important enough that Kitty Pryde
was willing to brave these outskirts
these derelict parts of New York outside
of the safe zones in order to meet with
Wolverine to attain it we also learned
from Wolverine that phase two of
whatever plan it is they have created
will begin
midnight but again we don't really know
what this is and we don't know what
phase 1 means from this point kitty
pryde heads back to her place of origin
minutes to say the places she originally
left to meet with Wolverine along the
way we learn a few things about the
structure of society at this point in
time and what we learn is that there are
three castes of people there are humans
and these are baseline people these are
individuals that have no potential for
genetic mutation these individuals are
allowed to breed now we're not really
given any other information regarding
these individuals we don't know if
they're allowed to hold political office
and we don't even know if there are
political offices anymore the next group
are anomalous humans and these are
humans that have the potential for
genetic mutation however these genes
have not become active these individuals
are not allowed to breed but we're not
really told whether or not they have the
same rights as humans or if their rights
are restricted to some degree aside from
being unable to procreate the next group
and the final and last and most despised
group in this society are mutants and
mutants are either exterminated on site
or they are rounded up and placed into
internment camps where they simply await
termination at some future point in time
eventually Kitty Pryde reaches the
internment camp in the Bronx where she
has been interred for about 13 years or
so maybe 14 years and after going
through an exhaustive and and as she
explains it a humiliating examination
process she makes her way through the
cemetery which is the first thing that
you see as you enter the internment camp
now this is a very iconic comic book
panel in comic books and the reason why
is because this confirms that almost all
of the comic-book characters in Marvel
that we have come to know and love have
been killed Susan storm Johnny Storm
Cyclops Jean Grey Nightcrawler
all these characters are dead now Kitty
Pryde continues to explain to us that in
this time of the original x-men there
are only four that remain there are
Wolverine
storm Colossus in Kitty Pryde herself in
addition we also learned that Wolverine
is alive I'm sorry that a magneto is
alive although he's confined to a
wheelchair and we were introduced to two
new characters we had never seen before
the first is Rachel Summers who is the
daughter of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
who is a telepath and a tell
kinetic the next person is Franklin
Richards who is the son of Reed Richards
and Susan storm from this point we
learned that the device that was given
to Kitty Pryde with regards to
completing the jammer goes towards
allowing the jammer to disrupt the
inhibitor collars that are on the necks
of these individual characters and of
all mutants who are in internment camps
and what we learn is that these
inhibitor collars keep mutants from
being able to use their powers and so
they are basically just people they're
not really able to do anything from this
point we also learned that phase one
involves Rachel summers by virtue of
being able to use her powers due to the
disruption of our inhibitor collar
sending the mind of someone into the
past into their past body in order to
warn the x-men of the impending event
that's going to take place in 1980 that
will cause the future to turn out this
way we realize that the person whose
mind is going to go into the past as
Kitty Pryde from this point we jump into
1980 and this is the point in which we
see Kitty Pryde in the past and at this
point the minds have not switched yet
Kitty Pryde is still her younger self
and the older Kitty Pryde is Mara is
presumably traveling into the past at
this point we see that the younger Kitty
Pryde has stumbled into the danger room
of the x-men and the x-men are going
through their drills they're practicing
you know making sure that they are on
par in terms of the use of their powers
in addition to their physical
capabilities as far as exercise and so
on and so forth the minds of Kitty Pryde
with the future and the Kitty Pryde and
the Past switch and Kitty Pryde falls
unconscious eventually she comes to and
at this point the mind of Kitty Pryde
from the future is in the body of Kitty
Pryde in the past at this point she's
astonished to see that so many members
of the x-men who had been killed are now
alive Warren Worthington the third
Nightcrawler
and so for her is really kind of a shock
but she immediately sets in with regards
to explaining a set of events that would
eventually unfold and lead to the future
becoming the way it is in her time now
at this point she tells the x-men that
they must leave and they must head to
the summit the Charles Xavier and more
batagor are attending in which Senator
Robert Kelley is giving testimony
with regards to why the rights of
mutants should be restricted along the
way she gives us the backstory in terms
of what it is it took place and what we
learned is that in 1980 the Brotherhood
of Evil Mutants assassinated Senator
Robert Kelley Charles Xavier and more
McTaggart at the summit that these x-men
are heading to and what we learn is that
in 1984 a crazy rabid anti-mutant
politician is elected to a position of
President he attempts to pass the mutant
Control Act however it's shot down by
the Supreme Court so instead the
administration reactivates the Sentinel
program and they give the Sentinels an
open-ended directive and what they say
is that the job of the signal's is to
destroy the mutant threat at all costs
but because of the fact that signals are
computers and computers are creatures of
logic they deduce that the only way to
do this is to take over the United
States and North America as a whole and
so that is the reason why there is no
order government in the future that's
the reason why there are no police
there's no standing army because there
is no human government anymore there are
simply just the Sentinels they rule
everything and all forms of society
exists below them from here we also
learn that when the Sentinels went on a
campaign to eradicate mutant crime they
simply didn't just stop there it wasn't
just the mutant threat it was any kind
of super-powered being and that's the
reason why Captain America is killed why
spider-man is killed they are not
mutants but they do have superpowers and
so they were viewed as a threat by
sentinels and they were eradicated just
like everybody else now eventually we
jump back into 2013 and what we see is
that Kitty Pryde is unconscious at this
point the younger mind of Kitty Pryde is
in ur future body but her mind is in
somewhat of a comatose state and so
she's not able to really contribute to
what's going on we also see that Rachel
summers Colossus Wolverine
Franklin Richards Marwan went blank for
a second Franklin Richards and everybody
else are heading through underground
tunnels in order to get to the Baxter
building which was previously the home
of the Fantastic Four but is now kind of
the central nervous system or the
central core of the Sentinel operation
what we also learned I think we may have
actually learned this previously before
we switched to 1980 was that the rest of
the world had become fearful of The
Sentinel campaign in North America and
so the rest of the world had more or
less kind of threatened that if the
signals had left the United States if
they had left North America and
exercised their campaign across the rest
of the world the world would retaliate
with nuclear strikes and as a result the
world itself would fall into a state of
total nuclear destruction now we realize
that this is kind of the timetable
that's been provided here the future
group must take some sort of action to
stop the Sentinel threat otherwise the
world as a whole will be destroyed and
so we see them heading towards this
patch to building in an attempt to stop
the Sentinel program but along the way
Franklin Richards is killed the group
continues to move on and eventually they
make their way to the Baxter building
now eventually we pick back up again in
1980 at the summit with Charles Xavier
more McTaggart and Senator Robert Kelly
at this point the x-men are are there
storm warns Charles Xavier of the
ominous future that Kitty Pryde had had
given to them Charles Xavier scans the
mind of Kitty Pryde and verifies this
claim and the future that she comes from
at that point the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants breaks in and they begin their
campaign of attempting to assassinate
senator Robert Kelley Charles Xavier and
more McTaggart from this point this
brings an end to x-men issue number 141
and the story continues in x-men issue
number 142 with the beginning of 142 we
again pick up with a Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants and over the course of this
comic we see several events taking place
we see the x-men in the past and 1985
new Brotherhood of Evil Mutants we also
see the x-men in the future attempting
to break into the Baxter building and to
destroy the Sentinel program Wolverine
is killed in the process along with
storm and
losses and the only two individuals left
are the unconscious kitty pryde and
Rachel summers now we switch back again
to 1980 and the x-men are successful in
defeating the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants the mind of Kitty Pryde is
eventually teleported back into her
future self and the younger mind of
Kitty Pryde is teleported back into her
younger self but we don't really know
what happens with regards to this future
timeline until much later in Marvel
comics in the storyline called the days
of feature present however the 1980
version of the x-men are left to wonder
whether or not this circumstance will
actually come to fruition if the send
the assassination of Senator Robert
Kelley is inevitable and they simply
postponed it if the assassination will
now never take place they don't really
know what's going to happen and so the
question kind of weighs on their minds
what's going to happen next so the
importance of the Days of Future past
comic cannot be overstated and the
reason why is because of the legacy that
this comic creates the legacy that's
created by the Days of Future past is
not limited to the concept of just the
storyline alone is also includes future
storylines that come about as a result
of the success of the Days of Future
past and one of the biggest reasons is
because the Days of Future past
introduced a concept that we hadn't
really seen before and that had been the
arbitrary death of comic book characters
with no real benefit to their death
taking place and the reason why I say
this is because when you look in the
past for example with spider-man the
death of Uncle Ben as it's depicted an
amazing fantasy number 15 which is
actually the first time that we see
spider-man is a death that goes towards
Peter Parker understanding the kind of
respect and the kind of responsibility
that comes with him possessing
superhuman powers and he moves from the
realm of being this individual that uses
his powers for selfishness to try to get
girls to try to get back at Flash
Thompson for bullying him to becoming a
more responsible person as a whole but
that's pretty much the common theme
prior to the Days of Future past an
individual dies and the death of that
individual will lead a team or another
individual to become something greater
than they already are
in the Days of Future past that doesn't
have
then the death of all these characters
takes place but we don't there's really
no benefit to it it's not as though it
leads to some greater future it's not as
though it occurs in some greater era a
piece or something like that it's simply
that most of the Marvel characters that
we know and love die and this really
dark and dystopian future is the result
and because of the popularity of the
Days of Future past because it was such
a huge event and still remains to this
day a mainstay among the minds of people
who rank popular comic books in assured
in a darker era in Marvel College and it
really allowed Marvel Comics to make a
turn make more of a gritty and darker
turn in terms of how they depicted
characters storylines and groups as a
whole in the Marvel Comics universe and
so we see storylines that come later on
the House of M storyline we see
storylines like the onslaught saga where
a multitude of comic book characters die
in a single event we see all of these
coming to fruition as a result of the
popularity that was established by the
success of the Days of Future past comic
[Music]
so to a degree is kind of up in the air
in terms of how the Days of Future past
is going to be depicted in the the
upcoming film that comes out in May of
this year but just father previews alone
we could see some pretty massive
differences for one Charles Xavier is
alive and as we establish Charles Xavier
was never alive in the Days of Future
past he was killed before the Days of
Future Passed comic took place we see
characters like Bishop popping up and
Bishop was really interesting about him
is that in some of the most common
depictions of the Days of Future past
Bishop is in this storyline for example
with the Days of Future past depiction
in x-men in the animated series we see
Bishop in this timeline however the
Bishop originates from a timeline that's
very similar to the Days of Future past
but it's not the Days of Future past
itself the bishop hails from a timeline
where a mutant named Hope Summers who we
actually see now and the current x-men
comics killed 1 million humans and as a
result the Sentinel program is
reactivated sentinels began the conquest
of the the same kind of conquest they
implemented during the days of future
past and virtually all forms of humanity
are subjugated below them but what we
see in the bishop timeline is an event
called the summers rebellion whereby
both humans and mutants make a stand
against sentinels and eventually
overthrow them although the relationship
between humans and mutants still remains
strained is still for the most part a
better environment than we see in the
Days of Future past and so we're not
exactly sure how things are gonna play
out I mean Wolverines mind going into
the past it's kind of a thing that has
people art a little bit but the one
thing you have to bear in mind is that
with the Fox version of Marvel films
Wolverine has really kind of become the
forefront character he's kind of become
the front runner with regards to his
popularity among individuals who go to
see these films but are not very
familiar with comic books it's the same
concept you see in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with regards to Iron Man Tony
Stark as he's portrayed by Robert Downey
jr. by no means is Tony Stark the
forerunner with regards to Marvel Comics
as a whole not by a longshot
that's a rule that could be best given
to either Spider Man or Captain America
however during the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is run up to this point we
really kind of see Tony start taking the
main stage he's really kind of the main
attraction and everybody else seems to
revolve around him so I'm not exactly
sure how the depiction of the film is
going to be done with regards to Fox and
I won't go as far as to kind of fan the
flames of the debate taking place
between which movies are better there
Marvel Cinematic Universe or the movies
produced by Fox but what I will say is
that I think that Fox and Bryan Singer
are going to be able to produce a film
that's reasonable enough to where it can
give good credit to the Days of Future
past storyline despite the fact that
there are some differences between the
cinematic version and the version that's
presented to us in the comic books with
that being said I'm going to go and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
and like Captain America Bucky Barnes is
a creation of Joe Simon and Jack Kirby
and is designed to be a propaganda piece
about where Captain America is a
propaganda piece that really hurts
towards adults Bucky Barnes is here
towards children and is designed to spur
support for world war ii among children
who in turn will influence their parents